Speaker 1: Let's go to Drew from Virginia.
Welcome to the show. Drew, what's on your mind?
Speaker 4: Hey, David, can you hear me okay?
Speaker 1: I can hear you beautifully.
Speaker 4: David, I wanted to ask you about
something that I. In regards to mass shootings
that I don't hear either the left or right really
talking about. Okay. Are you familiar with a
with the forensic psychiatrist, Dr. Park Dietz?
Speaker 1: The name rings a bell,
but I don't remember much. Park
Dietz? Yeah. He says he's been.
Speaker 4: He's been a a witness for a lot
of he's been a he's a forensic psychiatrist
who's been in a lot of high profile court cases.
Okay. And one of the things he's talked about
is that he believes that the primary
reason why we have so many mass shootings
is because national media always gives mass
shooters such major attention. Any time someone
commits a mass shooting, they will
always lead the story with sirens blaring
a photograph of the killer. They will they will
lead with the kill total. How many were injured?
They'll make it round the clock coverage. And
he has put out some videos talking about how
this has been shown to cause more mass
shootings. And he's given an example
before that there was a fad going around,
I believe it was in the eighties of people
putting bombs in other people's mailboxes and the
media would cover it. Right. And then finally,
the media caught on back at this time that if
we stop covering this, people will stop doing
it. Yeah. And they stopped covering it. And sure
enough, the amount of incidents of this happening
went down dramatically. And basically, he
recommends that the media try to localize
these stories as much as possible and make them
as unappealing as possible to every other market.
And I even wonder sometimes one step further
if websites like you, like, you know, Reddit,
Twitter, whatever should view this
as snuff material in the sense that,
you know, I feel like these are tragedies
for the local communities and not necessarily
something that needs to be on CNN or FOX News.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I am 100% sympathetic to this
idea. I think the difficulty is the practicality,
and I'll give you two to kind of thoughts on that.
But 100% and if there is no question in my mind,
I'm not saying mass shootings would stop if there
was no media coverage. Right. We still got to deal
with the guns, there's no doubt about it. But if
the shooters, even if they themselves are dead
or are in jail and unable to see the coverage,
they know from experience that when you kill 20
people, it's national news for days, if not weeks.
And to some degree, particularly for individuals
who, as we've seen, they often have no no romantic
relationship. Sometimes we talked about this
incel thing that often it goes on with the
mass shooters. They want attention from someone.
And that is that is a way to get attention, even
if you don't name them. Right. Not naming them.
Okay, fine. You don't name them. But eventually
the picture is shown. Eventually, people figure
out who it is. I think the difficulty is twofold.
Number one, the ratings that these things
generate for national media are explosive.
And, you know, we cover shootings for us.
They don't get good, quote, ratings. But
we I cover it because it's part of the story
on guns. I would rather not cover it at all.
I would rather not even talk about mass shootings
and give them no attention when all of a sudden
the entire discourse around guns and everything
explodes. We cover U.S. politics. I kind of have
no choice to at least talk about that. But these
things generate such great ratings for the 24 hour
streaming and news channel. So that's one
thing. And number two, objectively speaking,
when someone goes into a classroom and kills 20
people, it is news in the way that we've defined
news. So it's hard to imagine a world where
it gets no coverage. But I agree 100% with the
analysis that the coverage itself is a problem.
Speaker 4: Do you think at a bare minimum,
there could be any type of realistic solution
where the mainstream media networks could
ever have some type of it is maybe naive,
but some type of agreement where they at
least agree not to show photographs of the
killer. Because it's not that part's really
not extremely relevant to the tragedy, in a sense.
Speaker 1: And it's not at all relevant to the
tragedy. But it's a. Relevant to corporate media,
weaving a story that generates interest. And I
don't know how you get corporate media to agree to
anything that makes ratings lower because that's
at the end of the day, what it's about.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Speaker 1: But I completely agree
with the assessment of Parker Dietz,
as I understand you, telling us what it is.
Speaker 4: Yeah, Park Dietz, it I feel like
sometimes when I bring this up, friends of mine
or people who I know on the left, I'd even posted
this on your discord. And I was getting downvoted
and I felt like it was because I wasn't saying,
even though I agree, I agree with sensible,
like common sense. We need gun control gone
for want, of course. But I feel like if I don't
lead with that, like I kind of see this as the
bigger factor, even though they're both important.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, listen, take it to its
extreme conclusion. The extreme example would be
imagine that the shooter knew no one would know
about what they did other than the families of
the people you kill and no one else would hear
about it. If you look at the the manifestos
that some of them leave and whatever else,
some of them would not do this if they had
a certainty that no one would ever find out
other than the families of the people they
killed. And no one would even ever find out
the shooter's name. Some of them would choose
something different now. Maybe they would choose
something worse. I don't know, but I think
there is something to that. But of course,
we need to deal with the guns either way.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Yeah.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you for the call. I
appreciate it. Yeah, my pleasure. Appreciate it.
Thank you. Important and interesting. Let's take
a quick break. If you're holding on to talk to me,
just hang on a couple more minutes. We're
going right back to the phones in a moment.